[Music]
meagan Markel she will turn 37 on
Saturday but the celebration won't be
all about her instead of a big birthday
bash on Saturday Megan will join Harry
at the wedding of his childhood friend
Charlie van Straub NC Mary would be the
best man when his school chum ties the
knot with videographer Daisy Jenks both
were guests at Harry and Megan's royal
wedding in May Megan's birthday will
also be a meaningful day for the Queen
her beloved mother who died in 2002 was
also born on August 4th and did you know
the ones future Duchess did a sitcom
with Brad Garrett do you remember her
appearing on your show I do she was on
tilt up and she was a car salesman my
job is to sell you a car that suits your
lifestyle so let's start from there how
old you about 60 now she's a duchess and
I'm in foreclosure interesting what was
a very small scene she wouldn't stop
hitting on me
that was like and I finally had a go
Megan come on
Keltie spoke to brad at the premiere of
Christopher Robin where he's the voice
of Winnie the Pooh's pal your if anyone
wants to clap now is the time to do it
how did you get in in character I got
off my medication which really helps you
know it was a character I just always
related to you and McGregor plays a
grown-up Christopher Robin reuniting
with his childhood friends nobody knows
what Christopher Robin's like as a 40
year old man so I got it so I you know I
I had the freedom to create him the way
we wanted to
[Music]